[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY N. SMITH:
Thank you, guys.
I'm really happy to be here.
Thanks to Dave and company
for ushering me in,
hosting me so well.
I often ask for the
slot right before lunch,
because then I'm all
powerful-- and like what's
between the audience and lunch.
And it's fun to play that
game, but I think most of us
had lunch.
So I guess I'm
between you and work,
so we shouldn't just linger
as long as we can in Q&A.
I thought I would just share
a little bit about the book--
how I came to the story,
share a few passages from it,
and then get into a Q&A and sort
of learn what's on your mind
and have a kind
of back and forth.
So "Breaking and Entering"
is the true story
of a female hacker called
Alien and the birth
of our information
insecurity age.
And I should make
clear from the outset
that Alien is a
white hat hacker.
She is someone who is paid by
big businesses and government
agencies to try to break
into them in order to see
how they can be broken into.
She also does recovery
work if someone has already
been breached--
coming in doing forensics
and other analysis
to figure out what happened,
how to recover, and why.
And she also does a
variety of other things,
such as digital
hostage situations
and ransomware
cases, for example--
where you've got 24 hours
to have your hospital system
or law firm or tech
company get the data
that has been compromised back.
And you have to pay
$200,000 in Bitcoin.
And she kind of answers--
is that true?
Is there another
way to get it out?
If you do want to pay
$200,000 in Bitcoin,
how do you do that in
the next few hours?
How do you do that
without getting
triple-infected on the way back?
We'll talk more about that
in the sort of end of my talk
as I get to the
end of her career.
But I want to go back a bit.
So I guess I want to just
get a sense of the room.
Who here is-- I know there's
a lot of different teams--
who here is in security?
OK.
So I think I've got
about 15 or so of you.
So that means there's like
30 people in security and 15
are admitting it.
I've learned the math.
And I guess on the flip
side, has anyone here--
I won't make you tell
the gory details--
has anyone here been hacked?
So I don't see any hands.
So as the 15 people who
did raise their hand
could tell you, that means 40 of
you have been hacked, I guess.
10 of you have, you know it,
you don't want to admit it,
that's OK.
And we can multiply that by 4.
So then that's another
40 of you have and I
guess you just don't know yet.
Has anyone ever been
targeted by a hacker?
Have you ever
gotten an email that
might not have been from
the person who said it was?
There might have been a
link if you clicked on it,
it was a bad idea
and they make you all
carry some special device from
now on to do anything at work?
Anyone?
Yeah I got a call on
Monday from the Help Desk.
Or it can be face
to face, and we'll
talk about some
circumstances like that too.
So that is basically all of
us are targeted every day all
the time.
And so we're in an interesting
situation where hacking is now
a field where everyone--
not just at Google--
but is pretty well aware of it--
from little kids to
great grandmothers.
And all of us are targeted.
And we know that hackers
have an outsized influence
on parts of our economy, on
our politics, on our culture.
But we still-- for the most
part if you ask people,
what does a hacker look like?
They don't have a face.
So maybe they pop up a
popular search engine.
If you do an image
search for hacker--
gosh, you get
literally no faces.
You get shadowed figures in
hoodies or occasional Guy
Fawkes masks.
But don't worry, I'm sure
the fourth search result--
no, the fifth, the
20th, the 400th.
It just goes on and on.
There are no faces
to this field,
even though it is
so integral to--
we're all thinking about
it more and more often.
It's in the newspaper every day.
So as a writer, that's an
incredible opportunity.
Can I tell the story?
Can I show the face?
Can I show a field growing up?
You wouldn't necessarily know
it by the cover of my book.
It's not that different.
But I'm wedded to the world
that your search engine
results have created.
And so if I want to signal that
it's a book about a hacker,
I've got to have a shadowy
figure with ones and zeros.
But inside, I try to
put a face on the topic.
So how did I come to this story.
How did I get this
chance to kind of follow
hacking over the last 20 years?
Because if you think about
it, even when we have a face,
that face is like 30, 40
years old at this point.
It's like Matthew
Broderick in "War Games"
or Angelina Jolie in "Hackers."
So it's an incredible
opportunity.
So did I just start
following people
with hoodies down alleyways
until I found someone going
into the dark web before the
FBI could trap them in a San
Francisco public library?
I didn't.
I found this story through
an alternate investigative
journalism method.
I picked my daughter
up from preschool.
So I went to pick her up, and
there was a new classmate.
They were playing together.
The girls ran off
to the playground.
If you ever have
five-year-olds, you
know that the best babysitter
for a five-year-old
is a five-year-old.
They kind of cancel each other
out and they occupy each other.
It's mutually assured something.
So I'm talking to the mom and
she says, hey, what do you do?
And I think, this is
going to be great.
I'm going to be the interesting
person in this conversation.
I'm a writer.
I write these books.
I write these articles.
I talk about myself
for 10 minutes.
And to be polite, I
say, what about you?
What do you do?
And she says, well, tomorrow,
I have to break into a bank.
And I realized, oh, I'm
not the interesting person
in this conversation.
And that led to a longer
series of conversations.
And I found out, yeah, there's
this whole field that's real
and this whole profession that's
grown over the last 20 years
as I described to you at
the beginning of people who
have the same skills
as the bad guys
and do the same activities
in a high-end, professional,
organized way but do
it under contract.
You pay them big bucks for
the privilege of having
them try to break into you.
And hopefully you
get them to do it
before you've been broken
into already by a more
malicious actor.
So as I followed her story
and heard more about it,
I got really excited, because
even in the field of hacking,
people tend to specialize.
You get car hackers.
You get elevator hackers.
You get people working
in a particular operating
system or mobile phone operating
system or particular network
vulnerability.
But Alien had gone through
a huge variety of worlds.
And her career, if you will--
it didn't start as a career,
it started as a sort
of fun activity--
had grown up at the same
time this profession had.
So in following her story, I
could follow hacking's growth
from this sort of
skateboarding-like subculture
to what's now, I
think, $140 billion
cybersecurity industry-- and
not just a large and valuable
industry, but one that touches
every aspect of our lives
and gives us insight into
every aspect of our lives.
So the hope was if I can follow
a hacker in her footsteps,
readers can do the same and it's
not just what reading about it
or learning about it, you'll
experience it yourself
and kind of understand
our vulnerabilities
or our capabilities
in a new way.
So I want to share a few
passages to illustrate some
of the breadth of her world.
One I won't share just for
time reasons is the beginning.
She started as a
17-year-old at MIT.
Do we have any MIT grads here?
Got at least one.
Two.
Yeah, anyone do Course 19?
I got a smile and I
got a puzzled look.
So at MIT, majors
are called Courses.
So what your number?
What was your course?
Course 18.
Which is what?
Course 18 math.
What was your course?
AUDIENCE: 6-3.
JEREMY N. SMITH:
Course 6-3 which was?
Computer Science.
So they're numbered and
they go up to like 24.
19 is not an assigned number.
There is no
designated Course 19.
But, unofficially,
Course 19 is hacking.
And hacking at MIT
predates computers.
It does not directly
refer to computers at all.
It refers to
physical exploration.
So I was familiar with
part of this tradition.
There's this tradition of
elaborate, ingenious, physical
pranks--
like getting a police car
on top of the dome at MIT--
or having a complete living room
set-- couch, liquor cabinet,
even a cat, a newspaper--
upside down on the arch
outside the Media Lab at MIT--
or a working Tetris game
that's playable on the windows
of the tallest
building on campus.
And I was familiar
with these hacks,
but I didn't think about the
foundational skills needed
to do that.
You don't just kind get up at
noon or 8:00 or 9:00 at night
and say to your buddies, hey,
we should put a police car
on the dome.
Maybe you do that, but you're
not going to pull it off.
You've got to be able to pick
locks, sneak past security
guards, climb on
ledges, disassemble,
and assemble a car.
You've got to be able
to do that in the dark.
You've got to be able to do that
with a small group of people
you can really trust
to keep a secret.
And you've got to be
able to get in and out--
and the same thing
with the Tetris game
the same thing with
the living room
set, the same thing with
all these other hacks.
And pulling a hack is
what I just described,
but going hacking is
totally different.
You're exploring for
the sake of exploring.
You're going through
steam tunnels.
You're going along ledges.
You're climbing up
elevator shafts.
You're finding hidden or unused
spaces inside of the buildings
that everyone else
takes for granted--
and sort of goes through
as a normal civilian.
And that's exciting,
it's perilous.
And it has this direct
analog to computer hacking
where you're also getting
into forbidden spaces.
You're also working
off label with what
somebody else has created.
If an inventor
creates something new
and an engineer builds
to spec, a hacker
creates something
new with something
someone else has built to spec.
So you're often knowing spaces
in a way that the creator
themself didn't.
And that's a direct analog to
computer hacking we know today.
She goes from that world
into computer security
as it's becoming a new field.
And I thought I'd read a
short passage from a section
where she is working in
information security.
This is about 2005 in a hospital
system-- one of the largest
hospitals in the country.
We're aware, especially
now, that everything
that is a computer can be
hacked and that everything
is a computer.
But it still is
different to know that
and to experience it firsthand.
So, for example, in
a hospital, you're
connected-- on average when
you're in a hospital bed--
to about 11 different
medical devices.
Those have a network
card usually.
Those have an operating system.
It's usually built on Windows,
maybe a little more Unix
in the past.
Hey, maybe Chrome
or stuff right now.
And that means it's going to
have the same vulnerabilities
that those systems have.
Hospital equipment is
also often bought on a 15
to 20-year time cycle, because
it's millions of dollars.
And so that means when you
go to the hospital in 2019,
you may be experiencing
systems that
are serving you that have
the vulnerabilities of 2004
or 1999.
But don't worry, we
will have the security
we have today in
just 15 to 20 years.
So your grandchildren will
have the secure systems.
So looking at trying to protect
that and what that looks like
was really interesting in
trying to recreate that
through her experiences--
going on-site,
talking to her old
bosses and colleagues.
And I thought I'd
share a bit from that.
So what happens is she gets
a call from the network
team at the hospital.
And they're having
a bandwidth issue.
Something is
clogging the network.
And so devices aren't able to
communicate and some of them
are shutting off.
And that's a crisis
in a situation where
the flow of data is literally
a matter of life and death,
and people need to
be able to contact
each other across
wards, transfer
information, and the devices
themselves are lifesaving.
She goes to the office
of her colleague, Amy,
on the network team.
Amy was a lanky brunette--
27 or 28-- dressed in
jeans and a teal pullover.
Alien knelt beside
her in her cubicle
as they studied network
traffic information
from internet addresses
across the hospital.
"We started getting calls
two or three hours ago saying
the internet was
slow," Amy told her.
"I checked it out,
and they're right.
Some internal address is
just spewing traffic."
"It's got to be a
worm," Alien said.
Can you shut off the port?"
"I could, but I don't know
what's plugged into it,"
Amy said.
"What if it's an
important machine?
I don't want to
just cut it off."
"Let me see," Alien said.
She stepped up to the
keyboard and scrolled back
through Amy's command
history, double-checking
her investigation.
Amy was a pro, though.
On the basis of the
internet address alone,
the closest they could do was
trace the worm's origin point
to a third floor hallway in the
same building that held the ER.
Alien's eyes narrowed.
"Stay here.
I'll find it," she said.
Alien ran to the
elevator, popped outside,
and cut diagonally
across the campus.
Seven minutes later, wide
sliding doors separated for her
at the entrance to the ER.
Amy had called ahead for backup.
An IT staffer assigned
to this building
met Alien at the
third floor hallway
and showed her to the
right network switch.
It serviced a long,
quiet hallway.
By now, Alien had burned
almost half an hour,
but she was getting closer.
Back out on the hallway,
Alien stopped in front
of the only door in sight.
Doctors and nurses swished past.
Alien stepped back,
feeling out of place
without a white coat or scrubs.
When a nurse slowed
before the door, however,
Alien flagged her down.
"Hi, I'm from IT security,"
she said, and showed her badge.
"I need to get in here."
"Oh."
the nurse swiped her own badge
and the door clicked open.
"I'll have to
accompany," she warned.
"This is a restricted area."
The room was warm and dark.
Alien could make out
a few rows of what
appeared to be high,
narrow carts on wheels,
each with a monitor nearby.
It was vaguely reminiscent
of a server room,
but her entire concern was
with the network ports located
close to the floor.
Alien dropped to a crawl.
Using the same mag light
she'd had since her freshman
year at MIT, she swept the walls
looking for the guilty port.
20 seconds passed--
40, 60.
Finally.
Alien's beam illuminated a
yellow plastic port cover,
to which someone
with a label maker
had attached the alphanumeric
name of the infected machine.
Alien smiled in
triumph and relief.
She used the Meg light to
trace the black ethernet
cord coming out of the port.
It led to a profusion of
other plugs and cables
entering the back of the
machine closest to her.
She'd page Amy and Amy
would alert their bosses.
They'd get the problem
diagnosed as soon
as possible before the machine
infected anything further.
Alien stood up.
She felt the nurse
touching her back gently
to get her attention
without speaking.
"Turn that flashlight
off, please,"
she asked in a low,
but firm, whisper.
It was more a command
than a request.
Alien obeyed.
She felt a sense of
alarm, even dread.
Had she done something wrong?
Where were they?
There weren't any patients in
this room, she had thought.
It had no beds, only more
machines like this one.
Her senses suddenly
heightened, however.
She now heard the sound of
slow breathing all around her.
For the first time
since her eyes
became accustomed
to the dark, Alien
took a look around the room.
On each of the wheeled
stands was a teeny pallet
enclosed by clear plastic.
The pallets, she saw
now, held teeny blankets.
And under each
blanket was a baby--
a teeny one-- sprawled out on
its back and head turned to one
side--
all wired up.
These newborns were
essentially on life support
and fast asleep.
The room might resemble a
server room, Alien realized,
but it wasn't.
It was the NICU--
the Neonatal
Intensive Care Unit.
"Babies," she said to herself.
So experiences like
that are eye-opening,
because you realize
the virus, the worm,
the other vulnerability
can be a life support
system for a cluster of kids.
It's not a port you
want to pull right away.
From her work in security,
she moves to kind
of the other side of the fence.
And this was fun for me
because it was the intersection
of these two worlds--
this physical breaking
and entering she
had done as an undergraduate
and the computer security work.
She gets hired as a
penetration tester--
or pen tester-- testing
security at Fortune 500
companies, government
agencies around the country
and around the world.
And I thought I'd
share a short passage
from her first day at work.
We can all just think about
what our first day of work
was or our first day of work
at this campus and the kind
of onboarding process--
what was the first task you had
to do, the kind of nervousness
there.
And then think about this
as your first day of work
in a sort of new opportunity.
Ted Roberts-- Castle
Bank's head of security--
requested a private booth
at the hotel restaurant.
A friendly blond 40-year-old
man in a business suit,
he leaned across the
table after dinner
and passed both Richard and
Alien and his business card
and a signed, one-page note.
Alien skimmed the document
which she had written and sent
to Ted, asking him
to fill in the blanks
and bring it to their
meeting tonight.
"Castle Bank has
hired a lead defense
to perform physical
security penetration tests
and assessments of nine sites
in three states," it said.
Specific addresses
followed, starting here
with the bank's
regional headquarters,
and four branches she and
Richard had driven by today
doing local reconnaissance.
For the rest of the
week, Ted's note
authorized they were to probe
the facilities one by one
to determine if an uninvited
visitor could enter, explore,
remove equipment or
data, or rob the banks.
The letter closed
with instructions
on how to contact Ted
if they got caught.
"Your get out of jail
free letter," he said.
Richard harrumphed, but
Alien gave her best smile,
folding the letter and
placing it in her coat pocket.
"Thanks," she said, patting
the pocket afterward.
"I hope that we won't need it."
Ted signaled to a
waiter for the check.
"Good luck, but not too
much luck," he said.
Tuesday noon, the clock
tolled and office workers
exited the 20-story
headquarters.
Everyone was bundled
up and breathing out
steam on their way to lunch.
Moving in the
opposite direction,
Richard entered the
lobby to check it out.
Alien watched from the front
passenger seat of the car
clutching an empty
black laptop case.
No, not completely empty--
while she waited, Alien
reached her fingers
into the zippered
pocket and checked.
There they were beside her
get out of jail free letter--
fake business cards she'd
printed after dinner with Ted
last night.
Elizabeth Tessman-- Enterprise
Technology Specialist,
they said.
Right of the red,
Castle Bank logo,
above her real cell phone
number, a fake Castle
corporate email address, and
the address of this building--
each element copied from
Ted's business card.
Alien sighed,
shifting impatiently.
Then she sat up, quickly seeing
Richard approach the car.
"Did you get in?"
Alien asked after he had taken
his seat and shut the door.
Richard responded scornfully,
"there is no way," he reported.
"What do you " She said.
"All you've done
was try the lobby."
What about the freight
elevator or the storage room
with the open window?
What happened?"
"Forget it."
Richard turned up the heater
and made the shift the car
into drive.
"It's freezing," he
said, "let's move."
"We can totally do this."
Alien unbuckled her seat
belt. "Let me try," she said.
Richard shook his head.
"You won't get in," he insisted.
"There are turnstiles
and a security
guard watching everything."
You'll just blow our cover.
He continued gruffly, "let's
try the bank branches first.
If there's time,
we'll come back here.
We found plenty already."
"We're here now," said Alien,
"and I won't blow our cover."
Richard could spot a narrow
opening in a fence at 50 yards
and recite security
camera specs from memory.
Forthright, credible,
and confident he
was, like all of her bosses,
terrific at presentations.
It was clear, however, that
he had neither the patience
nor the aptitude for what
those in the infosec community
called social engineering.
Bluntly put, the term
meant manipulating people.
You might call it charming
them or, in some cases,
scaring them, but it
is always about getting
them to do what you wanted.
Whoever you were, the trick
was to assess the other person
and figure out how you might
talk him or her into something.
Perhaps the best name for
it might be human hacking.
Freshman year, for example,
getting Alex and Vlad
to "help" Alien with
her calculus homework
had been social engineering.
More recently, she had
turned her dinner out
with the bosses into a
kind of job interview.
Consciously or not, every
child or parent, teacher
or military leader, politician
or player on the dating scene
use social engineering.
For pen testers or their
criminal counterparts--
like those who sent
phishing emails
or persuaded victims to
empty their bank accounts--
the appeal was obvious.
Why bother breaking
into anything
when you can get individuals
to open their doors for you?
And because people, especially
men, were generally less
suspicious of women in this
kind of situation, being female
could be an advantage.
"It'll be fine,"
Alien smiled sweetly.
"I'll be quick and come right
back if there's any problem."
Before Richard could say another
word, she was out the door
with her laptop case.
Alien crossed the gray slate
floor of the spacious lobby.
Four hip-high stainless
steel gateways
stood between her
and the elevators.
Each was equipped with a
wedge-shaped black barrier
that receded when you placed
your badge on a scanner.
Then, as soon as anyone
passed the gateway,
the barrier closed immediately
preventing tailgating.
Next to the gates was a wide
marble counter, also gray,
behind which stood
a white-haired guard
in a crisp black uniform,
including a matching tie.
She walked toward the
badge reader system
as though expecting
to go through.
When the barrier
stopped her, Alien
acted startled, purposely
trying to catch the guard's eye.
Then she approached him.
"Hi," she said.
"I'm with IT."
We have a computer emergency
on the seventh floor.
I need to get up there."
She would be happy
to get in anywhere,
but knew from remote
reconnaissance
that this was the floor with the
most day to day office workers.
Up close, the man
looked even older
than she had originally
estimated-- at least 65
Alien guessed with
thin, gold frame
bifocals and permanent
creases in his forehead.
Still, he looked in excellent
shape-- erect and alert.
"You have to use your
badge," the guard said.
"Or are you on the list?"
He asked, pointing to a black
hardcover binder on the table.
"No, I'm in IT," alien told
him, re-assuming an old role.
"I'm new.
I just started yesterday."
The guard frowned--
"where's your badge?"
He asked.
"I don't have a badge
yet," said Alien smoothly,
"but my name is
Elizabeth Tessman
and my boss is Ted Roberts.
T-E-D-R-O-B-E-R-T-S.
Here's his card."
She lifted her laptop case
and placed it squarely
on the counter between them.
She tugged the zipper and took
out and slid him one of her new
cards as well as Ted's.
The guard entered both names
in his computer system.
"He's in here," he acknowledged.
"You'll need to call him
to get added to the list."
Alien opened her
phone and pretended
to call Ted and leave a message.
As she did so, holding
the phone against her ear
with her shoulder, she undid
the buttons of her trenchcoat.
"Hi, Mr. Roberts," she said.
"This is Elizabeth.
I'm leaving you a voicemail.
I'm really sorry to bother you.
They won't let me up
to the seventh floor.
I know it's an emergency.
Can you call me back please?
I'm really sorry, thanks."
She stood awkwardly in front
of the desk, checking her phone
and looking fleetingly
at the elevators.
The guard cringed.
"I can try him again,"
she said to him.
"I'm really sorry
to keep you waiting.
I know there was a big server
crash right before I left.
He might be in the data center.
I just can't leave
without fixing this.
I promised."
The guard was
clearly conflicted.
He looked down, giving her
card only a second's glance.
Then, though, he
waved her forward.
"Look, I know it's
important," he said.
"I'll make an exception,
just be quick."
"Thanks, I will," she told
him, "just as she had Richard."
Alien grabbed her laptop
bag and stepped forward
to the closest gateway.
The guard pushed a
button under the counter.
The barriers parted
with a whoosh.
Alien was surprised to feel
her heart pounding as she
stepped out of the elevator.
She'd taken much greater
physical risks in college,
but she'd never tried
to steal something.
For now, at least, there was
nobody else on this floor.
Alien moved quickly.
Most workspaces she
saw were cubicles
containing white desks
separated by six-foot
freestanding gray walls.
At the perimeter
of the floor were
the larger individual
offices of middle level
managers with glass
walls and doors.
Occupants of the cubicles
personalized their space
with photos and trinkets.
On every desk was a black
phone and a Dell laptop
connected to an external
keyboard and monitor.
Alien hefted a few laptops.
All were secured with cables.
She decided to try
the managers' spaces,
starting with a corner
office with an unimpeded view
of the downtown.
It had the same computer setup
though on a larger grade desk.
She lifted the laptop--
no cable.
Alien heard the elevator
ding, announcing
the return of the first of
the employees from lunch.
Two men chatted as they went to
their desks not noticing her.
She slipped out of the
corner office with a laptop
and walked past
two more employees.
Alien was positive she
looked as guilty as she felt,
but these employees
ignored her too.
Her heart was beating
harder than ever.
To a bank, nothing meant
more than its reputation
for trustworthiness.
The machine might have
confidential customer files
on it, Castle business plans,
corporate personnel records,
or all of the above.
An identity theft ring
exploiting that information
could make millions--
so could shady
stock market traders
or any of Castle's national
and international competitors.
And the fines and
settlement fees
once a big breach was disclosed
could run to eight figures.
Choice Point, the
commercial data broker,
had paid $15 million
the previous year
for giving up information
on 163,000 people.
Alien walked to the elevator
as confidently as she could,
smiling professionally at
others as their paths crossed.
Everyone else wore a rigid
badge with their name, headshot,
and the Castle logo clipped
to their shirt or waistband.
So she shielded those
areas with the laptop case.
The elevator opened
back in the lobby.
"Did you get it taken care of?"
The security guard asked.
"Yes.
Thanks so much," said Alien,
giving him a thumbs up.
She crossed the street,
opened the car door,
and slipped back
inside the Taurus.
"Nada."
Richard said, in a
told you so tone.
"I did it," Alien said.
She zipped open the case.
"I got a laptop."
"What?"
Richard's eyebrows rose
as he beheld her prize.
"Holy shit," he said.
So they call that M&M security--
it's hard on the outside,
soft in the middle
once you get past
the outer defenses.
There's a lot of
good stuff to take.
I talked to a
penetration tester who
was one of her
colleagues for a while.
You want to guess what
his specialty was?
Social engineering is
the way in, but then
what does he specialize in?
Shred bins.
He's like shred bins
are the greatest.
They take all of their most
confidential information,
they put it in one place, and
then they put it on wheels.
I was like, nobody
ever caught you?
He said, well, once.
I was wheeling one out
and the guard stopped me.
And I froze, they said,
hey, what are you doing?
And I just raised my hands.
And he said, that goes down
in the freight elevator.
So definitely made me
look a little differently
at shred days at my
bank, things like that.
So you start looking
at things differently
hanging out with these hackers.
Anyway, you rob a laptop
from corporate headquarters
on day one, you get
promoted pretty quickly
if that's your new job.
She's soon talking her way
into bank vaults themselves
and doing computer stuff
from internet cafes,
getting into an airline
reservation system,
doing recovery for
breached government,
taking a sort of
antennae on the highway
outside of a major
defense manufacturer
and sucking their data
under her computer,
and so on and so forth.
Eventually, she starts
her own company.
And sort of not on
purpose so much,
but as this industry grows up
and becomes a bigger and bigger
field, it takes on new employees
and becomes a manager and then
a CEO.
And she has this sort of
new generation of hackers
that she's sort of trained
and brought up under her wing.
And that leads to different
pressures and different sort
of perspective-- like
when you give birth
and you have to debug a
fishing site the same day
from the hospital.
So that was, again, sort of
parts of hacker storytelling
I hadn't seen before.
I thought I'd just
and the reading part
with a couple real short
passages from closer
to the end from her
kind of CEO days.
Luke, Gus, Sheryl, and two new
pen testers gathered around
the break table discussing their
latest work with client 0666--
a vast retail chain that needed
remote and on-site penetration
tests, mobile and web app
assessments, and a security
review of its credit
card processing systems.
"Who's on site now?
Asked Alien.
"Milo," Gus answered.
"He cracked their
wireless network
from a cafe inside
one of their stores
and then wormed his way into
the company's central systems."
"He got root on the badge
printing system," said Sheryl.
"He could add his name and
photograph to the badge system
and give himself access to
any building, any room--
you name it."
One of the new pen
testers piped up--
"we found this
internal database that
had the entire shopping history
of every single customer."
"Every customer?"
asked Alien.
She shopped at 666--
everybody did.
Gus hemmed, Sheryl tittered.
"What?"
said Alien.
"We found you," Sheryl said.
"The earliest entry
was from 1993,"
ancient history to
the 24-year-old.
"Congratulations."
Alien opened the fridge
and grabbed a water bottle.
She pictured the
entire break room
papered with her life story
as told through 666 receipts--
from her first bra to
her daughter's crib.
Last one.
In mid-September, Tree
Line Bank-- called TSC--
It's the pseudonym I use
for her hacking company.
On behalf of one
of its customers--
a construction company
based in Salt Lake City.
A day earlier, the
company's payroll manager
had clicked on a
phishing email link
that infected his web
browser with a man
in the middle attack--
allowing hackers to
see everything he typed
and even replace his familiar
Tree Line online banking
page with an exact
replica, asking
for additional credentials.
Only a second layer
of security requiring
special executive approval
for large wire transfers
had stopped the firm from
losing almost $60,000
to an offshore account.
Could TSC investigate and
find out what had happened
and how to fix it?
Susanna-- that's her COO--
sent Luke on site to image
any affected computers
and interview staff.
When he returned,
Milo took over,
using the equipment
in the forensics lab
to inspect everything carefully.
The payroll manager
had clicked on 19 links
in his many different phishing
emails, he discovered.
Alien volunteered to
help finish the job.
"I'll do the malware
analysis," she said.
To understand how
the malware worked,
Alien set it up in a
sandbox, or cordoned off
virtual machine environment.
This gave her the
digital equivalent
of a high-level
biosafety lab where
the software could be
safely stored, inspected,
and dissected.
Alien started by
viewing the page source
for the emailed link that led
to the man in the middle attack.
It was neatly written by
sophisticated programmers.
These bad guys are good.
Of late, the best black hats
had emulated successful Silicon
Valley entrepreneurs--
licensing the use of
their work through
cloud-based commercial software
suites called exploit kits.
To begin a mass
attack, you didn't
have to know how to
write a computer program
or even have your own computer.
You just logged
in from anywhere,
chose the kind of
hacks you wanted,
and paid by the
day, month, or year.
Some black hat services
accepted payment
by deducting a
percentage of the take.
Alien infected the
virtual machine
and then came back
48 hours later
to check what the digital
thieves had been doing.
The software began
by configuring itself
to run at startup, then it
phoned home once every 20
minutes seeking updates
or further instructions
from one of a series of modern
command and control servers
around the world.
"What do you want me to do,"
the program asked, in essence.
And the criminals at the
other end of the connection
could order whatever
they wanted.
"It's impressive," she
told Susanna afterward,
"and more than a
little frightening.
Not just in itself, but
for what it portended.
This wasn't solo,
hit and run operator,
it was the work of a group
of professional hackers--
just like TSC."
As she had gone from
novice to student,
student to practitioner,
practitioner to teacher,
and managed to manager--
all as a white hat hacker--
black hat hackers
across the globe
had followed a parallel path,
organizing their operations,
establishing reputations,
and finding clients--
and bringing in money
to their communities.
Alien had never realized it,
and she had never wished for it,
but one could even say she
had needed the black hats
to keep growing and getting
new opportunities herself.
"How many employees do
you think they have?"
Alien asked.
"I don't know," Susanna
said, "but their sales team
is definitely bigger than ours."
Alien laughed.
From Susanna's desk, she
picked up a little statue
she had given her.
"I wonder-- maybe on the
other side of the world
if there's an evil Susanna."
Susanna raised an
eyebrow wryly--
"well, then there would have
to be an evil Alien too."
Thank you guys.
So that's kind of
a taste of some
of the scope and the stories
and the kind of evolution
in the field and in her life
trying to use the storytelling
style to kind of express that.
I'd love to answer
any questions you
have about either the writing
process or other stories
from the book or other topics
that are of interest to you--
or teach me something
that's keeping you
up at night today, security
folks, or any other folks.
And I'll pass it on
to the next talk.
Comment on what's unique
or different or interesting
in particular about
her experiences
as a woman in this field.
So, yeah, I mean, she gets
that job breaking into banks
by taking a security class.
And the instructor there is one
of the leaders of a major pen
testing operation.
And when she goes into
that class, it is herself
and there are 19 guys.
And so that's a very
different experience.
And people-- when
they start the contest
at the end of that class,
which is sort of a hacking
contest, the guys kind
of shove her aside
and she, in that situation
at the beginning,
shoves herself aside-- or at
least lets them take the lead.
She's used to being
outnumbered and she's
used to being at MIT
where, as she put it,
guys were taking apart--
building helicopters with
their dad when they were four.
Everyone's like 15 years ahead
of me when I was a freshman.
So she doesn't think of herself
as more technically adept.
But what she finds
is her chops have
been built up over the time.
She had a boss between
those two things
at Los Alamos
National Laboratory
who would not let her work
start working for him until she
could do everything
without her hands ever
leaving the keyboard.
And so knew how to code.
She knew command
line, but she didn't
know how to play a
keyboard like a guitar--
and that level of extension
where the computer is basically
an extension of your body.
She was watching her classmates
who kind of nudged her aside
at that contest sort of stumble.
They kind of wanted a
graphical user interface.
They just weren't
quite as adept.
They didn't have the experience
she had had at the hospital.
And so eventually she sort of
starts doing it on her own.
And little by little, the guys
start lining up behind her.
And her fingers are flying.
And she's owning
system after system.
And for her, that was a
transformational moment
not because that was
when she got the skills,
but that's when she realized
that she had had the skills.
Because you have that
sort of image of yourself
as a freshman or
a kid often that's
based on an insecure moment.
And then here's a
moment of realizing.
I can do this.
And that sort of
sexism or exclusion--
or at least being a minority--
continues in a lot of
different parts of her career.
But she has to--
in conversations,
she says the default
when she finally does get
a job interview after that.
The default is if
a guy's talking,
the other guys assume that he
does what he's talking about
until he proves otherwise.
They assume the opposite
in her situation.
So she's like, I have to sort of
drop more technical references
early on to sort of
establish my chops.
At least for a time, she had a--
well, anyway-- it's
important to talk
about emacs earlier
in the conversation
when you're a female
hacker, I'm told.
So at the same time,
as I said, there
are fields even within
hacking particularly
where you're playing with
people's expectations
where that can be an advantage.
Sometimes you want to
be the innocent figure
that they don't suspect is
going to be an adversary.
Other times, she got
like a $2 clipboard
and she was the
authority figure.
You put on a suit and a $2
a clipboard and suddenly
you start questioning people
and they kind of like--
let me see your--
you go to the guard, you're
like, I'm doing a spot check.
Can I see your badge?
Can you show me--
I want to check the locks
on this whole building.
And soon you're
in the bank vault.
So you can flip roles too.
And then there's experiences
that, obviously, there's
no escaping their gendered--
like giving birth,
being pregnant.
These are experiences
only a woman
can have at this point in our
technological life at least.
And doing that while being
a CEO, while being a hacker
is, to me, another
extension of her badassery--
and women's badassery,
if you will.
So it was cool to
see that evolution
and also sort of
mentoring women and men--
there are some differences,
but that's in the book too.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Are you able to say what
years she was at MIT?
JEREMY N. SMITH: Yeah.
1998 to 2003.
Yeah.
Did I assume any
personal habits that I
changed in the course
of writing this book?
So two categories--
one, I started
doing crazy stuff because I
was hanging out with hackers
and trying to report and
understand their experience.
So I don't know--
how many of you
kind of like Def CON or Black
Hat, those kind of conventions?
Yeah.
So, as you know, there's
like 25,000 hackers
in Vegas for the weekend.
And you just kind of see
where the spirit takes you
in those things.
I ended up in a
shooting range that they
had set up like 30 minutes
out in the unincorporated land
in the Vegas desert.
And there's like
drone-driven skeet,
people are firing cannons
they made themself.
I was like-- where--
I've come a long way from home.
I also climbed up on the
domes at MIT and the ledges
and did that kind of stuff.
And I got a tour through Los
Alamos National Laboratory,
which is crazy.
It's like you're walking
through the Grand Canyon,
you take a right, and
there's MIT guarded
by people with machine guns.
Those were exciting.
And as for my own
personal habits, sure.
I started using
email encryption.
I started using full
disk encryption.
I was honestly more careful when
I Googled because I was like,
somebody is knowing what I'm
typing in one way or another.
And I have certain
agreements of confidentiality
to change identifying
details, but you guys
are going to know--
or your machines
are going to know
whatever I type in.
And I left my phone
when I took walks.
If I didn't need
it, why be tracked?
You have a story like that where
the retailer has the shopping
history.
We've all-- I'm just
going to make a guess--
90% of us have
shopped at shop 666.
And you realize that's
not an isolated thing.
We all shop, period.
And everywhere we go, that stuff
is stored, and data is forever.
So that kind of made me
think about situations where
I wanted to pay cash not
necessarily out of paranoia,
but just out of
intentionality if you will
and sort of thinking about
the price of convenience
and certain obliviousness.
And certainly things like
smart fridges and doorbells
are pretty terrifying
to me after hanging out
in internet of things village
at Def CON for a while.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY N. SMITH:
You are welcome.
So that's our time.
Is that what you're saying?
So I wanted to say--
I don't know if
I've lost my slides.
I may have gone
without them too long.
Say that again.
There we go.
I think-- I wanted to show
you guys one more thing.
Just as a sort of
example of the form,
I don't know if any of you guys
know a hacker named Deviant
in the Seattle Community.
He's a great
organizer with Tool--
the open organization
of lock-pickers.
And he was a source and a guide
for some of this material.
And he designed
a hacker bookmark
for me and for the book.
So it's a little bit
different material
than a normal bookmark.
It's a kind of flexible plastic.
On the back, you can see
this bookmark opens doors
and it's got instructions on
how to use it for certain kinds
of lock-picking or
physical entry--
a lot like Alien and her
classmates did at MIT.
We've got a few of these signed
by me and by Alien for those--
if anyone's
interested if you get
more than one copy
of the book then
that's a kind of bonus item.
So think about that
while supplies last.
And even if they go,
play with one too just
to kind of get a sense of it.
There's YouTube
videos of him using
it to get all sorts of places.
So, yeah, happy to
talk more one on one.
Thank you so much for your time.
And keep us safe and safer.
Thanks.